In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen."
The reading from the Sinaxadion for August 20th, on which we commemorate the Holy Prophet
Samuel.
On the 20th of the month we celebrate the memory of the Holy and Glorious Prophet Samuel.
The Holy Prophet Samuel came from Rama, a small settlement of the tribe of Ephrem.
His mother Hannah, one of the two wives of Elkana, was barren and had to put up with the mockery
of her rival when they went together as a family each year to the sanctuary of Shiloh
to offer sacrifice.
God, however, heard her prayers, and she gave birth to a son whom she named Samuel, which
signifies, obtained from God.
Once weaned, the child was consecrated to the Lord and confided to the priest Elai
at Shiloh to serve God there all the days of his life in the sanctuary before the ark
of the covenant.
Samuel grew in stature and in grace and lived in God's presence, and each year his mother
would bring him a little coat that she had made for him.
His frequent talks with the priests and devout men allowed him to learn about the law of
Moses, so that he was saved from the corrupting influences of the pagan cults, which were
then perverting the people who had recently settled in Canaan.
In this time of apostasy it was rare for God to reveal Himself, and visions were extremely
unusual.
One evening, however, as the twelve-year-old Samuel was lying in the sanctuary in which the
lamp which symbolized the presence of God was burning, he heard a voice call Him by name.
Believing it to be the voice of Elai, he hastened to his couch, but Elai sent him back to sleep.
The call came a second time, and Elai understood that it was God calling the child and told
him to reply, speak, Lord, for thy servant is listening.
As soon as he had uttered these words, the Lord stood invisibly before Samuel, and announced
to him that he was about to punish Elai and his house, for the impious conduct of his
two sons, who kept for their own use the victims offered in sacrifice by the people.
In the morning when Elai pressed him, Samuel told him what the Lord had said, hiding
nothing.
The Lord continued to reveal Himself to Samuel, all the people of Israel recognized Him as
a prophet, calling Him the seer, and respecting His words as the Word of God Himself.
As the sons of Elai persisted in their wickedness, divine judgment did not carry.
The Philistines inflicted a great defeat on Israel so that the Hebrews decided to bring
the Ark of the Covenant into their midst, the army welcoming it with great acclamation.
The enemy took flight, but instead of fleeing, fired with the energy of despair, it plunged
headlong into the army of Israel.
Thirty thousand Hebrews were killed in the battle, and the Philistines captured the Ark of
the Covenant.
One of those who escaped carried the news of the disaster to Shiloh.
He found the elderly Elai then aged 98, sitting anxiously at the entrance of his dwelling.
When the news that his sons had perished and that the Ark had been captured was announced
to him, he fell backwards, broke his neck, and died.
The Philistines had, meanwhile, taken the Ark into the temple of their God Dagwon, but
the next morning they discovered the idol lying on the ground, broken.
The hand of God was laid upon their people, and they were afflicted with tumors.
Reflecting together the princes of the Philistines decided to send the Ark back to the Israelites,
as the sanctuary of Shiloh had been destroyed, and the Israelites had no religious center
at that time.
The Ark was placed at Kiryat Yareem in the house of Abinadab, where it remained for 20 years.
Samuel the Prophet succeeded the priest Elai as judge of Israel, the supreme leader responsible
for leading the people oppressed under the Philistine yoke.
He undertook the spiritual renewal of the people by preaching repentance, a return to
the observance of the law, and the rejection of the worship of Baal and Astadi throughout
the land.
Fix your heart on the Lord, and He will deliver you from the Philistines.
Such was his program of government.
He organized a great meeting at Misbah, where the Israelites fasted and publicly recognized
their sins before God, and where the Prophet interceded for their salvation.
When the Philistines learning of this gathering decided to attack, the Prophet, at the request
of the people, offered a lamb as a burnt offering, and invoked the Lord, who immediately replied
by making a great crash resound from heaven.
The Philistines were struck with panic and defeated, and Israel was able to repossess the
settlements that had been taken.
Once peace was reestablished, Samuel continued to judge Israel at Rama, where he built an
altar.
Each year he would travel around the country sorting out disputes, and exhorting the people
to piety and the observance of the law.
When he grew old, he handed his powers over to his sons, Yoel and Abiyah, who were established
at Bershiba, but they proved unworthy of their father, for they accepted bribes and turned
aside from right.
The elders went to Rama to complain to Samuel and asked him to give them a king at their head,
that he might govern them like the other nations.
Preved by this demand, the Prophet finished by accepting their desire at God's command,
but he solemnly warned them that, with the introduction of royalty, they would lose the
freedom that God had chosen for them when he made them the only people who had the Creator
as their leader and God.
Samuel was then sent by God to Saul, the son of Kish, of the tribe of Benjamin, a valiant
warrior who surpassed all others, both by his nature and his bravery.
Taking him aside, Samuel anointed his head with oil, and declared that God had chosen him
to be leader of Israel, and to deliver his people from their enemies.
A glorious victory against the Ammonites rapidly confirmed this divine election, and Saul
was joyfully proclaimed king at Gilgal by all the people.
Samuel then declared that he had fulfilled his mission, leaving a king at their head, in
order to devote himself thenceforth to prayer and instruction.
He exhorted the people to fidelity to God and to his anointed, and to seal his words
he prayed and made the thunder roar and the lightning flash so that the sky was lit
up with fire.
Saul waged war against the Philistines.
When he found himself in a critical position, and Samuel had not arrived to comfort the
army that was about to desert, the king himself made the burnt offering, overarching his powers
and taking the priestly function to himself.
He had completed the sacrifice by the time Samuel arrived.
The man of God rejected all the excuses Saul put forth, and declared that as he had wished
to act alone and had not observed the divine law, the kingship would be taken from him.
Far from being drawn to repentance, Saul persisted in his pride, and prepared himself again
for battle, casting aside the priest who had been summoned to consult God.
He took the offensive, fighting on all sides against Moab, the Ammonites, Adam, Amalek, and
the Philistines, and delivered Israel by his bravery, yet these victories remained fragile
for they were based on human strength.
Having the offensive against Amalek at God's command, voiced through Samuel, Saul was successful
once again.
Yet instead of delivering all the people to the enathema, he spared King Agag and the
best of the cattle, offering to the Lord only the tainted herds, making himself once again
the uncompromising mouthpiece of the divine will, Samuel announced to Saul that this new
disobedience had sealed his fate, summing up his whole life of preaching, in a few words
he said, to obey is better than sacrifice, and to harken than the fat of rams.
Thou hast rejected the word of the Lord, he has also rejected thee from being king.
Saul begged in vain for forgiveness.
Samuel, after putting Agag to death with his own hands, departed for Rama.
While he was weeping for the fate of King Saul, God sent the Holy Prophet to Bethlehem,
to the house of Jesse, of the tribe of Judah, to anoint the young and handsome David as king
of Israel.
The Spirit of the Lord, having thus left Saul, he was seized by an evil spirit and suffered
periods of madness.
It was then that David entered into his service as his armor bearer, and he would calm Saul
by playing the harp to him, when the king was seized by an evil spirit.
He enjoyed his favor, but when he carried off brilliant victories and became the admiration
of the people, Saul's affection turned to murderers hate.
David was forced to flee, and he took refuge in Rama with Samuel, who was living a life
of contemplation there, surrounded by a group of prophets.
The prophet Samuel fell asleep sometime later, full of days, and the whole people of Israel
gathered together at Rama to mourn him.
He was afterwards honored as one of the great intercessors of the Old Covenant, on par with
Moses and Aaron.
Moses and Aaron among his priests, and Samuel among those who called upon his name, they
called upon the Lord, and he heard them.
His relics were solemnly translated from Palestine to Constantinople during the reign of Emperor
Arcadeus on the 19th of May, in the year 406.
Late temporarily in St. Sophia's, they were later placed in the church that had been dedicated
to him in the Hebdumon district, in the suburbs of the capital, on the 7th of October, in
the year 410.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.